Chris is with us in Washington DC
hi Chris welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
yeah better than I deserve what's up
great currently live in the DC area
housing market is obviously a pretty
crazy right now yeah and I are getting a
little bit nervous that if we don't buy
food prices will continue to exclude
currently we pay $1,700 in rent we have
about 60,000 saves towards a down
payment most houses in the area that we
live in are about 400 K to 440 K and
that range and wanted to really get your
advice on should we continue to rent or
should we buy are you out of death
completely out of that good and you have
an emergency fund in addition to your
$60,000 down payment yeah have about 17
K saved in emergency one I would buy by
a 15 year fixed where the payment is no
more than 1/4 of your take-home pay okay
great yeah Ben and you know if you do
all that now you may not be putting 20%
down on your first home purchase which
means you're going to have PMI that's
not the end of the world it's just
expensive p.m. eyes private mortgage
insurance you do want to do a Fannie Mae
loan a conventional loan and PMI will
cost you about $75 a month per $100,000
borrowed and you're gonna have three
hundred and fifty thousand dollars and
plus borrow three hundred and seventy
thousand dollars borrowed if you do a
440 right or 400 minus 60 before 350 so
somewhere in there so you know your PMI
is going to be expensive because you're
not putting down 20% house if you don't
do a 15-year fixed okay you do not get a
pass on math just because you live in
Washington DC that makes that you're
going to need to get your house paid off
in the next 15 years or ten you
if you want to build a net worth of
$1,000,000 or greater all of our data
points in our millionaire study indicate
that so I'm with you buying a house
without a full 20% down you've done a
great job getting to where you are be
conservative don't get house fever you
can put yourself in a position where
your house poor and you're stuck the
rest of your life and you can
rationalize your butt off by living in
an expensive market to do this and
you'll find something that's just the
perfect house and it's the dream house
and it's all that and it's none of that
it's a stupid house it's just a house
don't let the thing end up owning you
dude